لابد من الاشاره بدايه ان هذا التصريح هو
الاقصى للرئيس الفرنسي مانويال ماكرون
وخاصه بعد محاولات عديده لفرنسا ولدول
المحيطه بلبنان
لحذف السياسيين اللبنانيين على القيام
باصلاحات وانتخاب رئيس وفشلوا في ذلك
فلبنان اليوم يعاني من ازمات المتتاليه
نتيجه هذا العناد السياسي بحسب بعض
الاقتصاديين الذين توصلنا معهم بالتالي
ابرز ما جاء في كلمه الرئيس الفرنسي اليوم
هو انه دعم الشعب اللبناني اللبنانيين
اللبنانيات وطلب بالوقوف الى جانبهم ووصفه
الطبقه السياسيه بانهم ابتزازيين هو
يريدون البقاء في اماكنهم على حسابه الشعب
اللبناني بحسبه همم ماكره وبالتالي ايضا
اكد انه يزور لبنان على خلاف الاصداء التي
كانت داخل الاروقه اروقه السياسيين
اللبنانيه ان مكروه سيزور لبنان هو نفع
ذلك
ونفى ان يكون هناك اي مؤتمر دوليه للبنان
على عكسي ما طالبه البطريرك المارونيه
ماري بشاره بطرس الرعد عن دور حزب الله
اكد الرئيس الفرنسي ان لا حزب الله الدوره
على المستوى غيرنا الامنيه والسياسي وهو
يستفيد من هذا النظام كنتوا كالتواصلت مع
بعض القيادات السياسيه في لبنان لمعرفه
الاصدقاء بحيث انه لم يعلنوا او لم يكونوا
اي رده فعل الى العلم القوات والكتائب
اللبنانيه اكد لنا ان الرئيس الفرنسيه
يقصد الطبقه السياسيه وهم لا يعتبرون
نفسهم داخل هذه الط وهم يطرحون رئيسا
للجمهوريه وهو النائب ميشال معوض وبالتالي
بحسب القوات اللبنانيه الرئيس الفرنسي
يصوب سهامه باتجاه طريق الثامن من ازار اي
حزب الله وحلفائه والتيار الوطني الحر
التيار الوطني الحر بالتالي اكد لنا انهم
يقومون بمجهود كي يصلوا الى انتخاب رئيس
مكرون ايضا كان قد اكد على الاصلاحات
المطلوبه من البنك الدولي وبحسب بعض
القيادات السياسيه اللبنانيه هم يعرقلون
بعضهم